all right best on quarterbacks in the
nfc south chris
ask me the question i'm trying not to
cheat yep all right keep it blank
keep it blacked out pete don't erase it
yet all right this is not looking here
we go it's a gift for you happy 56 since
we've asked you
this already all right we asked you this
last year we'll see if you remember
maybe not maybe that just shows you how
old you're getting you can't even
remember
all right there's a notable former
player who shares your birthday
the dolphins drafted him but he went
on to make five straight pro bowls with
a different
team troy vincent yeah
good memory i already knew that i
already knew that he's five years
younger than me two of the day
troy vincent did i get that wrong before
yeah you got it wrong last
year i i do believe yes so all right
that's great you and troy vincent all
right
i didn't realize that that's a good one
good company but he's 51
yeah he's 51. five years younger five
years younger
yep a little more talented at football
than you just a little
uh slightly yeah slightly all right uh
best known quarterbacks in the nfc south
there's a lot of great players in the
nfc south
i i got to go christian mccaffrey though
even though we
we didn't see much of him last year
first it was an ankle then it was a
shoulder
but but he's awesome he can do it all
and
don't write off the panthers this year
but don't write off any of the teams in
the nfc south frankly we don't know how
it's going to play out but
if mccaffrey is healthy if sam darnold
with those receivers
defense all the resources they've
invested into it mccaffrey could end up
being a key key player
in that uh in that division and for that
team chris yeah
it's hard to argue that one this this
division is so talented
it's hard to figure out who's really the
first pick
it really is there's so many good
football players
um i guess i'm gonna i'm gonna stay with
running back too
i i think i'm gonna go alvin kamara
right off the bat here
i mean how could i not from what you saw
last year i mean it was special he was
definitely one of the best running backs
of the game and
i just feel like when like like
mccaffrey mike like when you have a guy
like that it's almost like he fills two
positions
you know when he's on the field it's
like always a receiver a running back
what do you want to defend him at we can
do a lot of different things here and
that's where they're they're both
brilliant that way but
you know camara can run strong between
the tackles
he's unbelievable at making people miss
in space
uh catches the ball just like a wide
receiver so
i i'll i'll go with alvin kamara it was
tough to actually figuring out who i
wanted to go with there
and and look it gets even harder as we
go forward there are so many great
players
but if if i were drafting a team
right now my next pick would be devin
white yeah
i almost made him one i hear you i i i
mean that i want that guy on my team
he's got the right attitude he's got the
right mentality he's got the right
leadership he's got a knack for making
big plays being in the vicinity of the
ball
he has a horse that's a plus that is
just because i think that's kind of cool
so
yeah devon white i i'm i'm not mad at
you there i honestly thought about
making him the first pick
i did i didn't think he'd go there right
yet so that's kind of what
made me sit away from it all right well
i'm gonna go to what i look at as i
think the second best defensive player
or maybe the first best it's really
close
i'm going to take grady jarrett next i
am i look at grady jarrod as being the
i'm trying to think about this and not
disrespect anybody
but i think other than devon white to me
that is the best defensive player
in the division i mean for what he does
on the inside there
you know he's strong but he's disruptive
as hell that's really the great
thing about grady jared it's it's not
about the the production of what he does
there
it's it's the disruption on a
play-to-play basis he's one of the best
interior defensive lineman in all of
football
uh so i can't pass him up
i i'm gonna i'm gonna circle back to the
offensive side of the ball
and i this one's not as easy as maybe it
could be
and a year ago i would have picked
someone else but i'll say mike evans
i've always respected the way he handles
himself quiet
soft-spoken goes about his business he's
got seven straight seasons of a thousand
yards
that's an nfl record and i just think
he's a great presence on that team
and maybe in year two with brady we're
going to see even more from him
uh bigger numbers more touchdowns etc
for one of the best receivers in the
game
yeah i i i'm uh i'm not mad at you there
i've been up
i'm actually i'm gonna go with michael
thomas with my next pick the same type
of thing
yeah wasn't the greatest year last year
and all that but damn he's still too
good of a football player
you know just has it all let alone i
mean
hey he's he's he's a size wide receiver
and he his size is a real real special
thing in the nfl his hands his
aggressiveness
his physicality over the middle he's got
as good of hands as you got
uh in the nfl peter we doing round four
do we have to take a break
all right i'm going back to my guiding
principle from round two who would i
take now
and want on my team he may not be the
best
best right now of the rest but i want
antoine winfield junior
oh you're just like yeah you like the
attitude of what he brings i want
i want him going forward going into year
two of his career well i mean i i hear
you i mean he's a guy you want on your
team
i'm not going to sit here and get into i
don't think he's the best
non-qb's of the nfc south the team
building thing
makes sense i hear you there but i'm
going to challenge you on that just
just a little bit uh i'm going to go
with dj moore
i'm i think one of the most underrated
wide receivers in all of football
you know i like guys i mean explosive
i mean it's it's one of the best yards
per catch and all the football
he's a real weapon everybody's going to
know who dj moore is by the end of this
year
i i i'm really calling that right there
with with better quarterback play in
year two under matt rule
okay uh round five of our nfc south
draft give me kyle pitts what the hell
everybody says he's gonna be a superstar
yeah let's let's go ahead get him i know
oh he's a rookie hasn't played yet so
what
so what he's transcended talent best
tight end prospect ever
give me give me give me i hear you i'm
not going to be mad at you there all
right i'm going to give
i got to give love to one big ugly i'm
going to go ryan rams check
for the saints i mean he's the best one
of the best right tackles in football
for sure
i got to give him a little love there
for sure um man we didn't get to shaq
barrett who i wanted to take next
i think he's another guy that we we
probably could have taken uh that
missed out here on this draft yeah
you're probably right oh well
i'm i'll take my five guys though i'll
take my five guys into any
football team that i would otherwise put
together all right that is it
for today hey florio just met today
that's very funny that's from iron mike
man look how big that kid is look at
that kid what a cutie
kid can read he knows a bad book when he
sees it thanks everyone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports